Fieback zu haben macht wirklich keinen großen spaß und erst recht nicht
Wenn man mit voller konzentration am start sein muss sowie die astronautin astronauten in der schwerelosigkeit jetzt sagt eine neue studie
Aber dass sie im weltraum genau mit diesem problem zu kämpfen, haben sie laufen regelrecht heiß
Wie gesundheitsgefährdend das ständige weltraum fieber wirklich ist und warum diese erkenntnis auch
Einen rückschlag für zukünftige marsmissionen bedeuten könnte, jetzt sind klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja, immer mal wieder gibt es ja studien die davor warnen, dass die raumfahrt
Tatsächlich, gesundheitliche risiken für den menschlichen organismus mit sich bringt einige studien der vergangenheit beispielsweise
legt nahe
Dass die sehkraft im all beeinträchtigt werden kann wahrscheinlich wohl ausgelöst durch die minimale schwerkraft dort
Jetzt kommt ein neuer punkt dazu
Weltraum fieber eigentlich ja erst einmal seltsamen alle ist es ja alles andere als warm umso wärmer dafür
Aber die körper der astronauten
Astronauten, das sagt jetzt eine neue studie die in der fachzeitschrift scientific reports veröffentlicht worden ist beteiligt waren unter anderem auch wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
Der charité in berlin ergebnis ganz konkret
Die körpertemperatur von astronauten den astronauten liegt die zahl zustand rund ein grad über dem normalwert
Der hier auf der erde gilt, der irdische wert liegt bei 37 grad dieses ergebnis stammt von messungen an elf astronauten
Astronauten jeweils sechs monate auf der iss verbracht haben, die dafür verwendeten stirn sensoren messen, die sogenannte kerntemperatur
Also, die temperatur
Die die inneren organe und das gehirn haben doch die temperatur der probandinnen und probanden stieg nicht
Automatisch an als sie dem weltraum erreicht hatten, sondern nach angaben, der neuen studie im laufe, der zeit konkret wurden
Die körper etwa zweieinhalb monate lang immer wärmer
Dann etwa pendelte sich die temperatur bei rund 38 grad ein und das könnte fatale folgen haben
Sagt das forschungsteam dazu später mehr, denn es kommt noch krasser die messungen zeigen, dass die körpertemperatur
Der astronautinnen astronauten sogar oft auf mehr als 40 grad ansteigt
Also, das ist ziemlich gefährlich schon hier auf, der erde sollte man es möglichst vermeiden seine körpertemperatur bei schwerer arbeit nicht ständig über
38 grad steigen soll, das sind doch die probanden knacken regelmäßig die 40 grad und zwar dann wenn sie trainieren
Das problem dabei sport gehört zum alltag im weltraum denn bei langen aufenthalten
Muss das team trainiert und fit bleiben als studie passt das mit erzählung von astronauten und astronauten bei allen, die immer wieder mal von
Unwohlsein und hitzestress berichteten ja vor allem beim training ja und das bedeutet abgesehen davon
Dass die eigene gesundheit ziemlich angegriffen wird
Ja, ist man weder körperlich noch geistig zurechnungsfähig, jedenfalls sich komplett, man trifft vielleicht andere entscheidungen
Also man es mit einem klaren, kopf tun, würde eine echte gefahr für die mission, also die neue studie geht davon aus
Dass dieses ständige weltraum fieber von den umständen dort herbeigeführt wird
der körper kann in der schwerelosigkeit nur schwer seine überschüssige hitze los werden selbst, wenn
dieser
der schweiß der verdampft weniger als auf der erde und
Somit wird die hitze schlechter abtransportiert und genau, das ist auch die erklärung dafür warum der menschliche organismus beim sport
Also, besonders viel schweiß steht im weltraum so schnell überhitzt weltraumflüge, die sich über einen langen zeitraum erstrecken
Wie zum beispiel richtung mars können dadurch deutlich erschwert werden
Das heißt es in der studie dieses weltraum fifa hat potenzielle auswirkungen auf langfristige weltraumflüge in bezug auf die gesundheit
Das wohlbefinden und auch auf körperliche
Und kognitive leistungen. Ja, das wäre starker tobak lange missionen wie eben die zum mars
Würden damit infrage gestellt, ja
Wir sehen mal weiter wie es was ich da ergibt bei diesen untersuchungen ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
Verpassen, wollt drückt man hier aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht dem genau auf die glocke nur
Dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert, wie geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken 1000 raketen zu mars ja ansonsten bis dann
Bleibt da?